hello John Perry here a couple of years
ago I was in Washington DC I was
speaking at the science and engineering
festival and afterwards I decided to go
do some touristy stuff I went to the you
know Washington Monument and a couple
different places one of which was the
Supreme Court and there I met this cute
little pug very overweight I was just
fascinated by the little guy
it's so interesting to me that something
like this evolved from a wolf it's so
bizarre behind me I have a wolf skull
you've probably seen this in my other
videos maybe you've wondered what it is
this is a wolf's skull and as you can
see that the snouts very long and the
teeth come down together pretty much
perfectly there's not an underbite
there's not an overbite they just clamp
down just just right and a pug of course
things are very different now I don't
have a pug skull and you have this guy
here this is a French Bulldog and they
actually have the same mutation the same
variation in their skulls the flat-faced
mutation and as you can see they also
have a very dramatic under bite the
teeth come up in front of the top of the
jaw when it bites down and I was curious
I wanted to know why is this what's
happening at the level of the embryo as
the embryo is developing inside that
womb what's happening to make the pugs
nose so short silly as the question
might sound why do pugs have flat faces
there's a lot of really interesting
things we can learn about biology in
general by studying this question and
added bonus we're going to use cake
frosting to answer this question
113 questions about evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number 13
why do pugs have flat faces so here is
my dog's skull collection these are all
dogs well technically the guy in the
middle here is a wolf but here we have a
Great Dane it was bigger than the wolf
we've got the wolf we've got a white
terrier and we have a French Bulldog the
French Bulldog is the most similar to a
pug that pug that first started this
question for me out on the steps of the
Supreme Court of our nation the really
fascinating thing about these specimens
is that in the wolf you can see that the
top of the snout is roughly the same
length as the bottom of the snout and
again those front teeth they come and
they're clamped down just perfectly it's
really nice in the Great Dane we have a
similar thing going on the the whole
face is a little bit stubbier but
essentially it's the same structure as
the wolf everything's bigger but the
structure is the same as in the wolf in
the terrier we have some really
interesting things that are happening so
notice first of all that the there is no
dip in the forehead and the wolf we have
this dip right here in the forehead and
the Great Dane we have that dip as well
we don't have that in the bull terrier
and also let me just get rid of the
bottom jaws here just hold the top
skulls in the wolf if I hold the the
braincase parallel to the floor I hold
it straight out the nose and the face
just sticks straight out to the side
there if you can see that if I do the
same thing with the bull terrier again
holding the braincase
parallel to the floor its face slopes
downward quite dramatically and if I
show you these from the bottom you can
see that the the bull terrier it forms
kind of this scoop type shape its skull
whereas the the wolf has a very flat the
roof of its mouth is very flat the roof
of the mouth of the bull terrier is a
very very scooped Lake
so that's interesting what's going on
there
and then here in the French Bulldog and
again this is a mutation that's very
similar phenotypically to what's going
on in a pug actually it's literally the
same mutation the nose is very short on
top and the mouth curls upwards why why
is it doing that it's so strange it
turns out that there is a set of genes
in dogs and we'll talk more about this
in a future video the exact genes and
and how they work but there is a set of
genes and dogs that controls the growth
of the top of the snout and there is a
different set of genes that control the
bottom of the snout and in the wolf the
top and the bottom grow at the same
speed in the bull terrier the top grows
faster than the bottom causing it to
curve downward and then the french
bulldog and in pugs the bottom grows
faster than the top and that causes
everything to arch upward at this weird
angle and just to show you how this
works I've whipped together some
buttercream frosting warning do not try
this at home you might get diabetes here
I'm going to simulate how it is that a
wolf's face grows so the blue here
represents the top part of the snout and
the white represents the bottom part of
the snout as they're growing as they're
developing in the womb and as you can
see here if I have them both growing at
the same speed more or less the same
speed bam we get a nice straight shape
that forms very similar to these
straight snout of a wolf
so this phallic-shaped frosting
sculpture is supposed to represent a
wolf's snout and I suppose it does a
pretty good job at that
if we look at the white bull terrier its
face slants downward quite dramatically
all we have to do to get this to happen
is we use more blue frosting than white
frosting we'll get that nice arch the
the blue as it's growing faster than the
white it just pushes the white down and
so you get this beautiful curvature that
happens there we have the bull terriers
face it its face looks kind of like it's
been melted downward
and then finally if we want to get a
flat faced dog if we want to simulate a
flat faced dog in frosting all we've got
to do is use a lot of white frosting and
almost no blue frosting at all and we
get this upward facing arch what I
showed you there with the frosting is a
really good example of how embryos
develop especially structures and
embryos that grow from a single point
outward so the snout which grows from
the face from that from the rest of the
skull works pretty much like what we saw
there with the frosting other structures
that are very similar to this would be
like the beak of a parrot it grows a lot
faster on the top than it does on the
sides and that causes it to arch
downward as it grows the talons of a
bird again they're growing faster on the
top than on the bottom which causes them
to curve as they grow people that have
straight hair their hair follicles are
pretty much perfectly round and so the
hair as it comes out it comes out at the
same speed all around if you have curly
hair the hair follicle is oval shaped
which causes it to come out faster in
some areas and slower and others and
that gives you this nice curls that come
out all of us started out as single
fertilized egg cells and that egg cell
was round and it began to divide and
grow it was pulling in nutrients and
materials from its host its mother and
it was using those to build itself into
larger and larger structures and the way
that transformed from a single sphere
into this bizarre shaped thing that is
you is that certain cells grew faster
than other cells this differential cell
growth speed is one of the major tricks
that embryos use to build the complex
three-dimensional shapes that we see in
you know adult mature organisms
obviously there's a lot more to
embryology than different cell growth
speed but it's really fun when a simple
principle can teach you so much about
your own biology in the next video we're
going to talk about the genetics behind
the flat noses found in pugs so
make sure to subscribe to this YouTube
channel and hit the little bell icon if
you really want to make sure that you
you catch that next video so long for
now as a farewell gift I give to you a
video of my dogs eating frosting
next question
you